les passagers à destination de vivonne
sont priés d'attacher leur ceinture dans
quelques instants
l'avion va décoller
[Musique]
là
elana
mais
[Musique]
olé
non
[Musique]
les bolides de malaga aller aux pays bas
débat
en
[Musique]
j'ai pris là
les données y arriver les réunionnais
t
[Musique]
avant j'y vais et je voyais le balafon a
dit il est content nous
jb a dit vraiment à la villa le 2 x x x
[Musique]
mais sa rivale
beau
[Musique]
g
m
[Musique]
les nominés
et et
et il y va car est tombé grâce à bakary
koné
[Musique]
oui
tous
[Musique]
on
beaucoup
[Musique]
merci aussi aux heures var bond de nous
avoir donné l'opportunité de le faire
connaître à modifier la forme on peut
emmener du soleil est aussi on peut
amener de la neige